hey everyone this is kevin from
thechestwebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the immortal game
of mcaults all
this is the most requested video i've
gotten recently do more chess analysis
of tall
for many he is their favorite player
he's the world champion in 1960
uh definitely one of the most aggressive
world champions we have
ever seen didn't matter if he was
sacrificing queens or all of his other
pieces
he was always on the attack said that
chess
every single game to him was like a poem
and he was the poet and he was just a
magician on the chessboard so i thought
hey let's go ahead and look at his
immortal game because you know if he has
a lot of good games
his immortal game is going to be a good
one and it is hopefully you enjoy it as
much
as i do this game particular comes from
1965. it's in the candidates tournament
he's in the semifinals his opponent is
bent larson
mccall tall has the white pieces and in
the candidates tournament the
semi-finals at this time they play
10 games best of 10. and this is going
into
the 10th game and they are tied now
mccarthy has the white pieces
and so he does need a victory here and
he waits till the the very end
for the gym of the tournament the winner
of this round goes on
to face british basket in the finals of
the canis tournament so we'll go ahead
and get started with
tall's immortal game starts out with e4
c5 the sicilian defense knight to f3
knight c6 pawn to a d4 here
after the exchange pawn 2 e6
knight c3 and then d6
this is the shivenigan variation in the
sicilian defense i have a separate video
on this
variation if you want to check it out i
have a link in the description below
as well as at the end this video there
will be a thumbnail you can click on
if you want to check that out but
white plays a bishop to e3 knight to f6
just development moves from both sides
and then f4 now this
is not the most common way that white
plays especially in 1965 bishop to c4
preparing to castle on the king side
you have bishop e2 a little quieter move
but still safe
and then castle on the king side macau
not looking to do that he's looking to
play extremely aggressive
so he plays f4 so he's gotten his dark
square bishop out
he now plays f4 which is the tall
variation named after himself
he's now looking to castle on the queen
side he just has to get his queen
involved into the action so after bishop
to e7
preparing to castle on the king side we
see queens f3 and then both sides
castle to opposite sides of the board
now usually when you see this in chess
it means that it's going to be a very
aggressive game both sides can throw
everything they want at their opponent's
king and not have to worry about
sacrificing
king safety usually if both sides are on
castled on the same side you're not
going to see pawns pushing up the board
because that's just
putting more pieces further up extending
what we call putting air in front of the
king not as
safe castled opposite sides of the board
you don't have to worry
about that so queen comes to c7 looking
to start
attacking on the queen side and then
knight to
b5 now the queen comes back to b8 but
this is a pretty tricky situation to
analyze and this is something that
as you're getting into chess openings
and learning what variations you want to
know
this is you can start to see where if
you don't really understand
all the threats it can get pretty tricky
so this knight and this
rook are both attacking this pawn here
on d6 so you can't just play queen to a5
start to attack on the queen side here
because just knight takes on
d6 the bishop takes yeah the rook's just
going to take right here on d6 white's
up upon a material
even if they don't take maybe they just
try to add more pressure here rook
to d8 okay well just now pawn to
e5 this is a great outpost for this
knight it's just not really going to
work out so we can see already that the
queen needs to hold on
to this pawn here on d5 but also queen
to d8 actually doesn't work because of
the move
pawn to e5 the pawn can't take as in
this rook takes here on d8
the queen falls you can't just push
forward here because then the knight is
going to fall here on f6
but then also you don't just want to
play knight to d5 you're still going to
end up losing material knight takes here
on
d5 you take our own knight that's fine
we could play
pawn takes on d6 attacking the bishop
they could play bishop to f6 and you
just take the pawn right away or even if
they just take the bishop that's fine
but then rook takes here on d5
and you can see whites up upon a
material now a lot of pressure on the
opponent this
bishop here on d6 is pinned down not
very good so
at the end of the day ben larson plays
correctly
and brings his queen back here to b8
now they stop the immediate threat of
the queen attacking on the queen side of
the board he decides it's time for him
to start attacking so he starts pushing
with
g4 a6 kicking the knight knight comes
back here to d4
there's an exchange in the center of the
board b5 starting to attack on the queen
side
pawn up here to g5 knight comes back d7
and then bishop to d3 this is lining up
for the light square bishop to attack
this h7 square which is a weakness only
being defended right now
by the king here on g8
black decides to go ahead and start
pushing on the queen side himself
and that is pawn to b4 and partly
because he probably did not expect the
next move
from tall remember this is one of the
most aggressive players of all time
and his brilliance many times wouldn't
even cross someone's
mind in this position he plays the move
knight
to d5 which is
very difficult to find if you're playing
even over the board and you have tons of
time to analyze the position
because it's so rare that people are
just giving up material
for a stronger attack later in the game
but that's exactly what tall does here
there's an exchange gives up his knights
he exchanges with his pawn here just to
open up for his light square bishop
this also has this almost imaginary line
here on
this d file and opens up this e file
that he can start to attack but really
wants to get this light square bishop
lined up
at this h7 square and decided you know
what this knight here on a c3
was really just playing defense and so
if i can take this pawn away
that's enough for me because it's not
always in chess
how much material you have it's how much
material you have involved into the game
tall knew that better than anyone
and he saw this position said i have my
bishop pair here i have some open lanes
here
and i have a completely open file uh i
can have both my rooks my bishops my
queen all lying down on my opponent
that seems better than what my opponent
has going on
so we have black push forward with
f5 knowing that he has to counter attack
in some way could have also tried maybe
g6 this seems like a reasonable option
for larson but played f5 here and then
rook
2 e 1 attacking the bishop here on e7
the bishop's under attack here on e7
black responds with
rook 2 f7 now this rook
is being overworked it's defending this
bishop here on e7
it's also defending this pawn here on f5
but tall looks at this and says it's not
wise for me
yet to go ahead and take this material
here on
f5 because now the knight can come back
to
f7 but still this rook still attacking
this bishop here on f5 but now maybe
bishop to e6 or maybe the
they don't want to exchange because
after bishop to e6 you could see the
knight come and take here on e6
and then maybe there's an exchange where
it comes down here to f5
but maybe instead the bishop comes back
here to d3
well in that case now the bishop can
take here on g5
the pawn can't take because it's being
pinned down by the rook right here so
white's in this tough spot maybe rook to
g1
this is not necessarily where tall wants
to be and he wishes he had
more uh pawn attack on the king side of
the board
and so we analyze this position and says
yes uh
this rook's being overworked but first i
need to start pushing more with my pawn
so he plays
pawn two h4 now bishop to
b7 and now is when he recognizes that
this is the opportunity
to attack here because the bishop here
on c8 was doing a good job
of indirectly defending and attacking
this square here
on f5 as soon as it moves white can
pounce immediately and he plays bishop
takes here
on f5 now it's a little bit different as
before
now if we were to see knight to f8 well
now we could see
bishop takes on h8 this is very
different because
of this pawn here on h4 because you can
start to push up the board maybe we have
king takes here pawn to a tribe very
different than before where we did not
move
that h pawn earlier so we see in this
position we don't see knight come to
f8 instead larson takes with his rook
here on
f5 and then the rook takes here on e7
black continues with knight to e5
and the pawn can't take because it's
been being pinned down by this rook here
he could take with his bishop but really
he doesn't want to give up more material
he wants all of his material on the
board to continue the
massive attack that he has going on with
this king side attack
and so instead he decides to play queen
to e4
removing his queen from the pin so now
he can take with his pawn if he wants to
and black responds with queen to f8
now this is getting the queen to the
side of the board where all the action's
going on that's the king side but also
attacking this rook here on e7
but guess what tall does not care he'll
give up any material on the board he
says oh you want my
my rook that's fine i already gave up a
night earlier you could take my rook if
you want to i'm going to go ahead and
take with my pawn here on
e5 now if you look at you say why don't
you just take the bishop here on
b7 but things get tricky with rook to f4
is it attacking the queen here you can't
just take the rook maybe queen
to e3 still holding on to the bishop
here
on d4 which is now being attacked but
this is going to lose rook down here to
f1 check
there's an exchange queen down f1 king 2
d2
checkmate right here so that's not going
to be good if the queen moves to
uh maybe e2 okay well now you just lose
your bishop here on a d4
and you already took the bishop here on
b7 so you you could get creative you
could play rook takes
on g7 check after the king takes bishop
takes
uh now this is this is better for white
but all of a sudden
you're still in a horrible position
you're down a rook
uh you do have a pawn advantage but you
know
tall's going to lose this game so he
recognizes you know what i'm not going
to take that bishop over here it's a
poison bishop i'm going to go down the
material
so instead i'm just going to give you my
rook if you want i'm going to take your
knight here i'm going to give you my
rook i don't need it anymore
and so that's what he does but larson
looks at and says
i don't necessarily want that rook i
think things are going to go poorly for
me i'm going to first attack your queen
here on
e4 i can always come back and get this
later queen to e3
still holds on to that bishop on d4
rook down to f3 attacking it again queen
down e2
and now we do see the rook come off the
board on e7
queen takes here on f3 and then pawn
takes
rook over here to e1 pinning down the
pawn
to the queen so many tactics going on in
this game so many pins going on
so many sacrifices very very complicated
positions
the tall somehow comes out of it on
every single one
in a better spot than he was before so
this pawn really like to take this
bishop
it cannot so swings the rook over here
to d8
rook takes here on e5 attacking the
queen queen to a d6 here
and then queen to f4
saying yeah you're you're in a tough
spot here this actually protects
this pawn here on d5
because you may look and say well how
does that work you have the queen the
rook and the bishop
all lining down on this pawn on d5 but
let's say
the bishop takes here on d5
well now just rook up here to e8 check
pretty much have to take with the rook
here now the queen is going to fall so
while black does have three pieces lined
up on this
d5 square this queen to f4 move actually
protects
that pawn now larson plays rook
2 f8 attacking the queen queen comes
back to e4
centralizing that queen but you can see
tal's doing a good job of having all of
his pieces work in harmony
also has a pass pawn here on d5 the only
pass pawn on the board
but all his pieces in the center are all
working together we're
black standpoint he plays b3 but none of
his material is really working together
it's just holding on for dear life
but there's just not much left here so
pawn takes rook down
f1 check king 2 d2
queen to b4 check but that's pretty
easily stopped with
c3 then after queen to d6
tall has the finishing move and that is
with bishop
2 c 5 and why is that such a good move
this is a great deflection
pretty much any tactic that you read
about in chess tall has done it in is
his
immortal game here but this is a nice
deflection getting this queen away
giving up material he's already given up
a knight a rook what's a bishop here
after the queen moves
you can see rook e8 check rook here to
f8 and then queen to e6 and this is
where tall was trying to get this queen
away from it's protecting that
e6 square this is check and after the
king to h8
then queen to f7 the reason this is so
dangerous and why larson resigned in
this position is
this queen here on f7 the rook can't
take it it's being pinned down by
this rook here it's going to the king is
going to fall but also this queen
protects not only this pawn here on
d5 but also the pawn here on f2
there's no additional squares that
larson can go
to pose any threat and so he recognizes
the end is near
and he decides to resign so tall's game
fantastic player so aggressive always
sacrificing material looking for
a strong attack so hopefully you enjoyed
watching
this video if you did if you wouldn't
mind please hit
the like button also if you made it all
the way to the end of the video if you
wouldn't mind leaving a comment below
and then putting a smiley face
at the end of your message i would
appreciate that lets me know
who actually made it to the very end
if there's other famous games that you
want me to analyze
you can let me know in the comments
below this video was created because so
many of you said do
more videos on tall so that's why i did
it happy to do others
upon request but thanks so much for
watching the video and i'll see you guys
next time
you